foreign
hi Mark welcome back
we had our first date we did what kind
of did we have phone dates all the time
well we have fun dates but you know we
had a lemon drop day so yeah I feel very
special we're drinking lemon drops
happy New Year
is it good happy New Year it's very good
yeah right it's cheap in it I made him a
lemonger
fresh lemon juice
so what are we going to talk about
oh my God Mark where do you want to
start everything I mean you were so
interesting last time your story is is
fascinating the brothel part I'd love to
hear more about the brothels
yes so on the first episode you've
worked at several brothels right yes
four different ones so I give the bigger
lines on the First episodes yeah but the
Brazil is a huge part of my life we
don't even leak the tip of the iceberg
Mark we just scratch nothing yet you
know like yeah I have quite a long life
you know and many many things to talk
about but the brothel
for sure it's important to talk about
because we do have one state in America
that do allow
um legal prostitution yeah and I think
it's awesome to have legal platform the
only thing is we don't talk enough about
what happened on those legal platforms
which
are borderline unacceptable and again I
told you we don't have an HR to call to
call we absolutely have nobody to check
on the girls
um if the
if the environment is clean and not all
style nobody checks on us
there is not one job in America that
finds you eat at the brothel we get fine
we get fine okay there is a lot to talk
about so I did four different houses my
first one was the Bunny Ranch which I
did not stay too long and I'm going to
explain why then it was The Love Ranch
north which is a mile away
till then is half house okay same owner
same exact owner just it's a mile away
and it's maybe since I guess the Bunny
Ranch was highlighted on TV by HBO it
was like the main house like the number
one house where you put like kind of the
top cats right
we're going to talk about that then
there is the love range which to me it
was the most Friendly House I loved it I
loved it there and I stayed there for a
while then it was The Love Ranch South
in Las Vegas
which was a complete dump and we're
gonna talk about that and then
there was cherries
cherries is time to talk about you so
we're gonna talk about that now let's
talk about the Bunny Ranch personally it
was awesome and I did real freaking good
uh very fast okay and the thing is
Dennis Huff was not there when I arrived
he must have been on one of those
business trip and this guy I have to
admit that is a complete marketing
genius because good publicity or bad
publicity it would always say it's
publicity okay and so you can see this
guy on TV really like
I don't know like representing the the
wrenches talking a lot about
um you know us the girl and how he
changed things and it did change a lot
of things you gotta understand that the
burning Ranch and all the Denny's half
houses are not a locked down house okay
you're gonna understand that Brussels in
America are locked down houses they are
[ __ ] prison okay legal modern
slavery you girls can't leave we can't
leave we get fine if we do we get
fifteen hundred dollar fine if we leave
cherries not the bunny okay bunny is
another story so
Dennis off was super Flex okay when it
comes to us going in and out of the rain
she was super flexible
the rule is if you leave the ranch more
than 24 hour you get a retest okay we
were absolutely free to live after our
shifts which was 12 hours ends at the
Bunny Ranch you are allowed to pick your
shift not at Sherry's and we're gonna
talk about that so now at the Bunny
Ranch you pick your shift personally um
my energy kind of progress my Sexual
Energy cannot progress as the day
progress like by the time the sun comes
down like I'm like I'm I'm like a
vampire I'm ready to [ __ ] like a porn
star but it like that's me there'll be
some girls they're really good in the
morning I am good like
more at night so I would do the 2 p.m 2
A.M shift however if I want to come I
want to stay in the Parlor until 5am I
can which was great so that shift was
like kind of the best for me all right
so at the ranch at the Bunny Ranch where
like there is a lot of cool stuff okay
we have a gym we have like a tanning
salon
um we have a 24-hour bar
um Sandwich Bar a bar two but a sandwich
bar salad bar food is accessible not at
cherries at the Bunny Ranch okay so they
treat us quite well do you have a
lighter Mark oh my God is that a blooper
you're the best so
actually here
oh yeah I think
you're my Flame
okay so at the ranch you have enough
food accessible you have the Turning
Salon you have a lot of stuff that are
amazing okay cool
personally
the first day
I'm going to take my breakfast and I'm
washing my plate you know I'm doing the
dishes like a good girl you know I'm not
gonna just leave the dishes right there
I'm getting I'm getting yelled at but
the stuff lady what are you doing
so I'm like
I don't know what am I doing you never
do the dishes here
I'm not
excuse me by all means I will never do
the dishes here again I could get used
to that but by the time you don't waste
your breakfast
your room is done you have a maid who
came and actually just done your bed
fresh new pillow beautiful what the [ __ ]
you know no let's talk though about
the different little things that they do
at the Bunny Ranch so when you arrive
you are put in a [ __ ] room okay it's not
like the cool room no you put in a [ __ ]
room you are a new girl you need to
prove yourself to the house you are put
in a [ __ ] room at cherries they give you
the same room everybody is is equal when
it comes to the room not at the Bunny
Ranch and they play with that I'm gonna
tell you how they play with that so if
you're a top cat you're gonna get the
sweet with the jacuzzi and if you are
bringing a client to that particular
Suites it's gonna book you easier that
if you have a [ __ ] room okay so the more
you progress in the range the better
your room gets
okay so then
it keeps the girls in check in a way
they're always in competition to get the
better room if you are very good number
you are top cats you get this room so
they have this little strategy with the
room
and so personally at the ranch at the
Bunny Ranch I did like I think three or
four weeks until Dennis arrived
okay so Dennis
you see him on TV
is six foot five is a huge auger and the
first thing he greeted me with was a
little song friendship friendship touch
my wee-wee okay so this is how I got
greeted by Dennis half the guy that you
see on TV that is quite serious and when
is at the ranch
the body language everything completely
changes I mean the dynamic that you're
gonna have one on one with denisov
as one of his girl has nothing to do
with
what type of dynamic you're gonna have
as like a client male right so it's very
like
definitely feeling you are putting you
on his lap asking you to like hunt and
come on his leg well personally I don't
hump and come on a leg okay uh first of
all it's hard for me to even come period
so I'm not gonna come on your knee all
right that's not gonna happen but you
would literally make sexual display of
intention in The Parlor and pick a girl
boom so the thing is girls who are
really enthusiastic doing it Daddy Daddy
and doing all kind of dirty stuff for
him so he's used to it you're used to it
I mean
at the same time he is getting fed a lot
of intention is getting fed a lot of sex
daddy daddy everybody wants to kiss his
ass and so
here I am and I am not altering myself
at him I am not at all comfortable when
it's not like you know testing me out
pretty much like like it was at one
point like a competition of the girls
who had to do like the like moaning like
ah
well back then I couldn't do that okay
like here you have like Air Force Amy
like ah ah oh like this girl is like
next [ __ ] level like you cannot even
compete with her you know and friendship
is your turn
I remember I froze like
dude
I can barely fake an orgasm like
organically so you're asking me to just
not have a dick in me and do that
so it was like this awkward moments
where I quickly understood okay am I on
the level of those girls
and so on Thursdays you have the tea
party so those are kind of cool and cute
you have to put like gloves and you have
to put hats and cute little lingerie
Mark you faster than your Shadow you
might you might want to just keep it
there Mark is my future ex-husband
like but yeah look at that you're
already ready
is that your way to propose
you're proposing on camera
yes twice
one more time and I'm about to lose my
sheet marks watch out
it's about to get raped you invited me
to Cabo and I and I turned you down
and then I went to chulum you actually
missed the jungle I don't know what's
wrong with me
Mark yeah you broke my heart at that
very very moment I'll make it up to you
the year is Young
all right where was that why was I
thinking well
where was I you're talking about the
Dennis Hoff sitting on his lap
um
the Tea Party
so the tea party again you put the hats
you put your gloves on you're in
lingerie but you want to look like a
lady so you like a remix between like a
lady and a sexy [ __ ] and
you talk about the problems and at the
end of the reunion you have to say
something positive to not you know
create dramas so during that tea party
we drink tea and we talk about the
problem and my problem personally was my
bed was squeaking like a [ __ ]
it was like having a whole Orchestra
in my room I cannot you know it's my
tool my bed is my tool and I cannot have
something that make the clients boner go
away okay so I highlighted the fact that
I need an absolute new bed this one is
broken it needs to go okay
well next thing you know yeah I'm
getting a new bed and that bed I had no
idea that it came with the price
so I'm arising I'm not sure what the
[ __ ] I was but when I arrived to the
room
this bed is so high that I have to climb
it's like a canopy it's a princess bed
even myself I could not even afford a
bed like this and now it's mine so
I received a text from Dennis how you
like your bed
thank you so much Daddy like I love it
it's amazing and then I'm receiving a
text knock knock is right behind the
door
and now I'm having Dennis
huge dinnies with big blue eyes
well we're going to test the bed
the thing is thanks God or
you had diabetes and his dick did not
work so
all our hearts
is from him is is faced in between my
legs with his big blue eyes are you
gonna come are you gonna come licking my
[ __ ]
for the longest five minutes of my life
I think at this very moment this is the
day I consciously clicked out
and not myself
I wasn't there like I remember putting
my my uh it was so awkward I was so
uncomfortable if I did not click out
it was going to traumatize me you know
sad day
it was the first day of learning how to
be comfortable at being uncomfortable
and it's crazy that it was with Dennis
Huff
the guy on TV that I was like what the
[ __ ] like I'm working for this guy and
then like boom like you have a complete
different Dynamic a sexual perverted
Dynamic with him and since so many girls
does it
it does not even know how to read your
body language anymore like he is so used
to have all those girls
um showing them that
it did not even see that the last thing
I wanted to do was that
are completely clicked out are you gonna
come are you gonna come and ding ding
ding ding ding the bell of the lineup
and I remember going like this and tell
him I'm gonna run I gotta run I gotta go
work
I got Beats
and in my book
the title is Saved by the Bell
I'm gonna cry
[ __ ] see I'm told you I'm PMSing
ah [ __ ]
yeah
what is [ __ ] I don't even know why I'm
crying I never cried that day
my heart is beating and everything I'm
really giving it in my head
so yeah and then like yeah I had a new
bed
and that day yeah it was like the very
first day you uh did you learn how to
click out
I don't know if I'm I'm like crying
about this very situation or about like
the overall and it's like a wave hitting
me a little bit
yes but um it exposure to this job
at this very moment of my life behind
you it was a long time ago so I was
young and um
um I was trying to figure [ __ ] out I was
trying to you know tough myself up
because I was like like my girlfriend
told me in the first episode like you're
so stuck up you know you have a broom in
your ass like so I was trying to like
figure out my limits and everything so
can any woman do this kind of work
no definitely not
yeah it's not for everybody
it's not for everybody for sure as fun
as it is for me and honestly like using
I'm crying right now I'm user but no
trust me it's like I love this freaking
job
but as fun as I made it you can be a
torture for other ones if you are forced
to do it it's a torture if you are if
you hate this job is to torture a lot of
girls at the Bunny Ranch hated it and
let's just pretend Mark that I'm meeting
a mechanic is working on cars and he's
telling me every day how much he hates
cars
I would ask him why you work on cars and
so those girls at the Bunny Ranch I
would ask them like why are you here
you know because let's go back to the
ranch though I would like
I would go out of like a session like oh
my God this guy was awesome or like I
would like be so positive about like
what was happening to me the girl's like
shut the [ __ ] up when she like it's not
where you like it
I'm like shut the [ __ ] up there's no way
you don't what are you doing here if you
don't like it you know what I mean and
so a lot of girls they were really
doubting me like it's no way like you
you like sex like that I'm like
bro just guys just give me a serious
genuine orgasm you know and absolutely I
had [ __ ] pleasure why would I
actually torture myself in whatever I
left the corporate world because I
tortured myself there not to torture
myself in another area that would be
[ __ ] insane you know what I mean I
would not leave a torture to go get
tortured somewhere else doesn't make no
sense all right so let's go back to the
ranch and and and you know the dynamic
so
as soon as I had a chance to go to The
Love Ranch which I kept hearing about
like it's the lower end house but it's
fun there blah blah Denise doesn't go
there I was terrified of him there is
not one one human on earth that I was
more intimidated by but not even my dad
not even my grandpa my nobody on earth
made me so intimidated
like every time he's like friendship
friend she touched my movie it would
like be in the Parlor trying to put me
on his up I was so uncomfortable every
[ __ ] time that when I went to The
Love Ranch
hahaha
it's run by women there and the two
Madam were awesome
Adrian for sure Adrian you oh you are so
cool this woman
she had four kids and you know how she
get the job at the love range
I think she was some type of school
teacher and Dennis asked her all right
so you pretty much work with kids it's
exactly the same but with more drama and
she took the job and she was actually
like this beautiful like big beautiful
woman like
super like recall 14 you know like a
house mom a proper House mom and then it
was Diane that eventually became the
main one and
same thing she was cool like all right
friend she go take a break go take a hot
baths you're going to feel better after
that like little stuff like that so I
personally like The Love Ranch better I
also became a bigger fish in a smaller
Bowl because at the monument you always
like porn star girls that are like on TV
they're girls that are a famous girl
that were famous from the HBO show you
had crazy Air Force Emmy I did a party
with her I didn't even know what to do I
mean I think something she was
intimidating the [ __ ] out of me
it's I don't even know how I arrived in
this VIP room with her she was like
looking in the Parlor for extra girls
and I ended up being there and here is
air force semi completely [ __ ] up
there is this dude
laying down and it was that song right
here right now right here right now and
she's literally like caging the guy like
slamming him
right here right now it's just screaming
at him right here right now and I'm
looking at this like
what I'm doing here what I'm doing here
so I was kind of the assistant you want
condoms do you want Lube the guy was
like terrified you can see like Emmy you
are actually scaring me here I'm trying
to even do something she's literally
blocking you like no that's my client
okay you're just gonna be there and
watch okay what I definitely printed
information that night
so yeah as soon as I could go to the
love range and be in the environment
that was a little bit um
I don't know how to explain like um less
old style less um competitive super
competitive super competitive depending
Ranch they slash your tire there those
girls if you have a nice car they will
slash your tire if you have nice hair
they're going to put bleach in your
shampoo they will sabotage you okay with
no mercy no [ __ ] Mercy I mean me like
I don't even know how I handle it I
don't know how I handled it they don't
sabotage me per se but they were like
they were mean like oh my God they were
like bullies
um oh yeah I don't know how to explain
you like like my room was My Sanctuary
like
you know and then every once in a while
you find like super super cool girls you
know super sweet girls that you can
actually like relate to I had this girl
Harmony she started like just sleeping
in my bed it must have been like a
comfort to to her like eventually can we
do like sleepover almost like you know
like pajama night or something and she
would like sleep in my bed and just hug
me you know yeah I love the little oh
and so then The Love Ranch was cool
and uh
lots of things was happening at the
Lauren she was almost like a Sisterhood
okay we had karaoke nights we had
special nights
um Denny's birthday was a [ __ ] show I
gotta say like this guy knew how to
throw a party that night he had every
single of his VIP come in
you know during his birthday and he was
Las Vegas style you had entertainers
clowns people on stores you had like
literally everything going on there it
was awesome you know and then you had
Street vibration like 300 different
bikers coming and you could make like
thousands of dollars just kissing at the
kissing booth
yeah like there was a lot of fun stuff
and then
um
Dennis opened a new Brazil
in Las Vegas so the love ranch sauce
wait I need to get a sip of water
so he opens a new
he opens in your Ranch
near Las Vegas and it's a complete dump
I mean I actually never seen this before
the thing is I didn't know that yet it
is really like
telling the girl that if we go there we
can keep a little bit more of a
commission so it was 50 50. okay but if
you go there since it's a new house and
they're trying to launch it you could
keep 60 of the commission
so I agree to go there because it was it
would ask a lot of girls and like you
know it's my first month there I kind of
want to be like all right
away
from Dennis Huff all the way there
near Las Vegas and I'm arriving there
and I'm realizing it's a [ __ ] dump
like like I actually remember even
thinking like you don't even live like
that why would you accept this
because mind you you get charged 25 per
day for room on boards
oh look now we can
now we get married forever I didn't ask
you you just like read my mind
hi
so here I am in this complete dump what
was great about it is once the guy
arrived there it's an hour and a half
from Las Vegas it's in the middle of
nowhere nowhere nowhere it's almost like
imagine Death Valley and you have a
brothel there this is pretty much The
Love Ranch House
and as soon as we could see a car coming
because you see the car coming from like
miles away there is nothing anyway so
like there is one one straight road so
you see the car like
Scarlet coming from either the coming
for us or they're here to shoot snakes
Okay so we know the coming and once
they're coming they kind of stuck
because I mean we were like six girls
imagine how pathetic
you drive from Las Vegas you know like
ready to [ __ ] like you know
um hire beautiful girls and you arrive
in the middle of nowhere in a dump and
you have six girls to choose from
which was great for me I kept getting
picked I made more money there than
delivered uh North so
but I stayed eight days I said listen
I'm not staying here period that's it
mind you if you because something it was
not a lockdown house but they say if you
get out of the house you cannot go to
Las Vegas well mind you I had a super
cool client he came he booked me for
multiple hours and he I told him like I
need to get out of here I'm suffocating
like I can't
I can't like I oh even like right now
I'm feeling it like and it's like you
want to go to Las Vegas I just you know
pay you for an outcall and like let's go
and I'm like can we do a check to Soleil
and it's like [ __ ] here I'm like you my
hero so now we're going to the to the
window is booking me big [ __ ] time
we're going to Las Vegas I mean I have
five hours at this point oh my God we
went to Series so late to see car
and I remember like looking at the sky
and thinking that could have been
because I did gymnastic I did the circus
and that show in Las Vegas I remember
being like a little girl crying like oh
my God oh my God it was such a beautiful
show and then when it was done let's
drive back all the way to the top you
know oh my God it was a treat Mark and
so after eight days I left
I get back to the to the to the love
wrench North
so
there is a lot of things that would
happen at the at the the ranch that
would not really be technically
acceptable and uh for example the
bartender we start like hitting hitting
on you and it was a lot of conflict of
interest
employee would literally pop like
popcorn in and out in and out always in
your employee always new drivers because
mind you that we have drivers to do runs
for us
okay and so those drivers they would get
fired all the time it was like conflict
of interest all the time listen if you
have conflict of interest with the bus
then it's half you're gonna have a
conflict of interest because everybody
is sending the tone right there
is setting the tone as a matter of fact
Dennis for example he brought a
photographer that was 24 hours at Durant
she had his own Bangalore
the photographer would photograph you
know charge you because we knew we were
going to get charged but it's like we
can do a trade otherwise the
[ __ ] literally moved into the
[ __ ] Bunny Ranch as a photographer
and so that he could like just like get
like free sex against pictures and
that's what Dennis would allow okay
another Another Story Another crazy
story
I am at the bar at the Lawrence at the
Lawrence not even at the Bunny Ranch and
there is this big dude
at the bar nobody's talking to him
okay so I'm going and like we're having
like a deep conversation about like
World War II and the Jews is literally
like teaching me history we're going
into an intellectual conversation at the
bar
and then Denise arrives okay
line up girls lineup
okay we're lining up the guy that I'm
talking to for like 30 minutes at the
bar is Ron Jeremy
very good friend with Dennis Huff okay
so now we're lining up because it's from
Jeremy's birthday hooray happy birthday
Ron
and Dennis is asking him to pick a girl
he's picking me
okay
we just had a [ __ ] conversation about
World War II and the Jews and everything
is teaching me because apparently he was
a teacher he's teaching me about stuff I
don't even know and now we have to go
into a sexual mood
and I am going with wrong not knowing
how much I'm going to get paid because
when there is a bunch of Dennis friends
you go pretty much you're not splitting
with the house but you're not sure how
much you're getting paid and here I am
with Ron Jeremy making a display of
everything you can do uh it can give you
Goosebumps like I mean it does uh it can
it can it made me squirt are you [ __ ]
kidding me this guy for the first time
made me squirt he told me buckle up grab
on the sheets and he's doing this like
crazy action
holy [ __ ] so now I'm having Ron Jeremy
with me in my room for an hour and we're
cracking up and he's showing me like
literally how like if you clap your your
clap your finger Easter goes up your
clock it goes down honestly it was like
I don't know fairly decent with me I had
a good time but the thing is you don't
you don't know how much Dennis is paying
you you're going blindly like this like
a pepperoni pizza on a silver platter
like here fancy well in picture you go
so the first thing I do when it's when
it's over you run to the window and you
you asked Adrian like how does she pay
me he's like oh you put a salad on your
book
it's not bad sometimes you put 300.
Dennis will put 300 sometimes she hunted
on your book like it would do like all
kind of weird stuff and if you are like
is like favorite it'll hook you up 100
like Dennis will hook you up but if you
kind of like resisting him and not like
interested to him
um no and then I'm gonna tell you an
example so when he liked me and it was
really after the friendship friend she
touched my wee-wee all the time what he
does after the Tea Party he picks his
girl some girls from the Bunny Ranch
some girls from The Love Ranch in a limo
we go out in town those are awesome
because you get to the limo everybody is
hating on you because it's not everybody
who's getting picked so all those guys
like
looking at you going to the limo like
going to you know with Dennis in the
restaurant to the strip club I mean he
bring you once he picks you to go to the
limo it's an awesome [ __ ] night you
know so
but then you quickly understand if you
know his favorite no more you're not
going in the limo no more and there is
on this competition of like
here Daddy I'm ready to suck a dick
daddy here Daddy I'm ready to suck a
dick too and so this is why
obviously it was completely confused
no no more he was testing everybody
honestly if he would he was not even
forcing himself on you it was just
literally like
taking things for granted almost like it
was entitled you his girl
you're gonna show Daddy what's up and
that's it because since every girl does
it or most girl does it who are you to
say no and here you are in a position
where if you don't do it you're grateful
because this house is bringing you a lot
of money absolutely so I love the LA
Ranch because they didn't cheat you like
that even though every once in a while
you tell the Madam hey my [ __ ] is
hurting I can really care that can
cannot take no more and she simply tells
you go take a bath you'll feel better
yeah you cannot just clap your finger
like a faucet you know and just make
your [ __ ] feel better sometimes you
just like literally worn out they make
you wear a sponge
when you have your period 100 you got to
work you know you have cramps go take a
bath like the best was like the solution
to every [ __ ] problem there you know
and so
um then obviously you hear about
cherries cherries cherries everybody is
talking about cherries oh my God you can
make a lot of money not cherries
so you know
I like new energy I like new things I
was writing a book as I said so I'm like
let's go to cherries and see what's up
there laughs
share erase Okay so
they hired me in no time same thing like
I I uh emailed the pictures I told them
I was interested to be an addition of
their team let's go like couple days
later I was already there so the thing
is like I had no idea how nothing worked
at Sherry's because I'm used to the
Bunny Ranch I'm used to the love wrench
I'm used to how they do it you can go
out you you're free to go after your
shift I mean it's really very flexible
there
huh not at Chase okay
let me explain you and it's [ __ ]
crazy I I must have like arrived with
300 of my money so when you arrive with
your bag first of all
you have a guy with a dog security all
the stuff coming and like going through
your [ __ ]
they took my 300 bucks and put it on my
books do not arrive with any money at
cherries Ranch because let's say that
you did not make no money that's 300
bucks you had that you arrived They're
Gonna Keep it let me let me talk about
this
cherries was [ __ ] crazy so I am
arriving
and it's TSA style I mean we're talking
about security is it opening my socks
they're going through my penny trying to
see if there is no drugs in there or
anything in there and they find my weeds
obviously at the very ratio was no
problem no problem we had like an actual
little shade to go smoke with a baby
monitor to hear the lineup okay they
didn't they said whatever makes you feel
better as long as you're functional okay
so we had a little baby monitor we
didn't miss a bear we could smoke in the
little shade to keep us warm because
it's cold uh cherries no no no no no no
no no so the guy the security was
actually nice I had like a little jar of
weed like this like a little quarter of
wheat maybe seven grams of weed and he's
telling me go put that back in your car
do you really [ __ ] think that I put
it back in my car no no no I tried to
find like like a paper towel like I put
it in my penny I remember like the
orders like
I smell like weed like a [ __ ]
come on there's no way they just smell
it but here I'm back to the ranch
cherries uh we without my 300 bucks
who's winning my penny and I'm being put
in the transit room because until you
pass the STD and all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you have to stay in the transit room
cherries is Hardcore when it comes to
monitoring you have camera everywhere
when you arrive at cherries's Big
Brother
it's almost like you [ __ ] sign up for
the real world you have camera here here
here here here here here here right now
right there right there right there
right there right there and right there
they tell you if you talk to the staff a
150 fine you cannot talk to the staff
um if you miss a lineup it's a 150 fine
if you fight it's fifteen hundred dollar
fight uh fine
if they find drugs or money
it's a fifteen hundred dollar fine if
you leave early it's a fifteen hundred
dollar fine they keep your money for two
weeks at cherries your commitment to
cherries has to be two weeks if you
break that commitment it's a 1500 fine
at the Bunny Ranch you don't have that
type of thing they understand that there
is life there is sometimes moms with
kids that need to break the two-week
commitment without getting [ __ ]
charged 1500 uh but no actually don't
give a [ __ ] what is your situation once
you sign up you sign up and if you break
your commitment of the two weeks
rotation you get fined fifteen hundred
dollar at the Bunny Ranch you get paid
every single day they cannot hold your
money they do not hold your money okay
absolutely just like cherries but
cherries to hold your money for two
weeks why do they do that because if you
are one of the underdog da start owing
money to the house
now they can hold that money you have
nothing when you leave let's talk about
that actually so you have two different
categories of girls in the wrenches you
have the top cats and The Underdogs okay
and there is nobody's fault it's those
girls are hailing so much when they are
The Underdogs and you're the top cat
there is nothing you [ __ ] did
differently to be a top cat okay you
look better you are younger your body's
cooler there isn't something that the
client is picking versus her but she's
gonna hate on you and call you a dirty
Hustler Okay so
those girls they start accumulating
a whole they start accumulating 25
dollars
room on board every day plus the doctor
on a weekly basis is 200.
25 a day for room on board so let's say
you're an underdog the first appointment
you have everything goes back to the
house your check or your envelope is
zero and now you starting getting in a
level of life where you [ __ ] for a roof
and salad bar and Sandwich Bar literally
now if you bring a thousand dollar to
the house that 25 room on Board gets
waived okay
I would pay one time the 25 when you get
STD tested and you have no choice not to
work so you they charge you that one
night
every single night was completely waived
it's impossible not to [ __ ] bring a
thousand dollar to the house to waive it
if you don't you're an underdog and
there is nothing you can do there's like
either you need to go and realize that
this is not for you because this is not
you retiring from the job is the job
who's going to retire from you it's very
Cutthroat very very Cutthroat but those
girls are gonna try to rub you try to um
make you feel bad like oh my kid is
getting skinny can you up front me 500
bucks I give it to you next time never
girls if you work at any ranches do not
upfront any money ever to those beaches
I got literally like raped by them by a
by a woman
I mean she was arresting me for 1500
bucks do you really think I got my
fifteen hundred dollar and choke on me
to even think that this [ __ ] Street
[ __ ] druggie was going to give me
back my 1500 bucks it was my first two
weeks at the ranch I quickly understood
this is not real world there this is
ranch World okay and you have to
literally like be like Cutthroat thick
skin and tell them what's up no my money
is my money and I'm sorry you cannot
make your own maybe you need to [ __ ]
go sleep burger at Burger King this is
not my [ __ ] problem anymore when she
took that 1500 from me I felt raped you
know what I had to do for this 1500
bucks [ __ ]
here you know you are so those girls do
not trust them they are not trustworthy
it's not every girl that are gonna have
the principle that I had and since
the only thing that I had was me as a
point of comparison I never thought that
a girl would be able to rob you
yeah they do they absolutely do
mercilessly and when I try to get my
money back you know what she said I'm
busy doing my hair with my money [ __ ]
excuse me and she was 10 years older
than me yeah 10 years older than me so
quickly understood those girls were not
to be trusted so you have the girls are
doing really really good the girls that
are in a complete whole
and there is this whole like Dynamic of
toxicity between the two groups right
and so this is what you had to go
through at the ranch a lot
the competition is Hardcore you know
they put you in conviction with the
rooms every week you are you know
announced as the top cat who's the top
cat the three first one are getting
gifts the other one have to witness that
imagine being with 18 girls and on out
of the 18 girls only five are gonna get
gift and everybody's clapping for them
and so that's the strategy of Dennis
have to always keep the girl like you
know in check right well um
I don't really think it's right to do
this public display of who's the best
who's not because it creates tension
everybody's in your face everybody's
always looking how much you're making
you always have to be careful in your
room that they don't [ __ ] take your
money at the Bunny Ranch because you get
paid daily so you have to always lock it
so let's go back to cherries though so
cherries
great money okay absolutely they were
right there is nothing that was actually
fake or untrue of the reputation when
you arrive at cherries it's a facade
okay it's Las Vegas style you have a
grand piano and a statue and a spa and a
swimming pool and everybody has the same
big huge rooms but you cannot talk to
this to the staff you don't really have
access to the food 24 7. I was stuck in
a VIP room for like five hours with the
guy it was too late to order food you're
kidding me I just [ __ ] like drain
myself with this client and I cannot eat
right now so when you cannot eat you
have to use a driver and send him on a
run you cannot use your car at cherries
yeah your car that you just parked no
you cannot take it you're on the lock
down you cannot leave you cannot leave
it's a [ __ ] prison completely I need
nature I need to breathe I need
meditation sometimes just taking my car
and just driving the top down feels good
you know and they don't allow you that
at all okay also they do random check at
Sherry so if they find money in your
room that means that you did not return
the money and you [ __ ] up the house
1500 fine so they do random check when
they do a random check on me they found
my win
that I brought in my penny no yeah they
found that weed it was wreaking it was
like good steak you know so like the
security because when they raise your
room like they're like five people like
going everywhere it's such a rape there
it's a brothel okay so like a prison
you're kidding me I'm getting random
check buy the stuff to find my weed okay
so now that I have my weed
and like I'm pissing myself obviously
because now I have to go to the office
just like you know you live in the
corporate world not to deal with like
pissing yourself
and now you're pissing yourself again at
the browser yeah right so here I am
her name was Gina and she got herself
the men pimp here's a woman definitely a
Butch that caught herself
the man pimp I remember you're not
Eugena okay Eugena you are not the main
pimp you are dinner so now she has my
weed and she's telling me all right
friend she it was eight days eight days
at cherries okay I'm supposed to stay
two weeks she's like all right
this is not supposed to be in our
establishment because we can actually
get closed if we get checked well come
on what is the [ __ ] like chance that
you get checked for a [ __ ] having weed
no chance okay so uh that stays in my
safe
or you can actually go with that fifteen
hundred dollar sign
so I tell her okay I've been doing
actually pretty good I'm not a vegetable
you can see me interacting with the
client I'm not completely High okay like
it was some girls they were clearly
taking stuff they were like their jaw
are going crazy come on now and here I
am with my little weed and you're going
to give me [ __ ] and try to find me
fifteen hundred dollars I told her no
you're not you're not going to take
nothing as a matter of fact you're going
to give me my weight back and the fine
you're not going to find me and I'm
gonna explain why you are not dealing
one with one of your little prostitute
trainer [ __ ] desperate and [ __ ] no if
you keep my fifteen hundred dollar right
now I will put not only the French news
the European news and we put every news
on what's going on behind your closed
door I would tell the story about the
girl that put a tampon and missed a
lineup and you charge her 150 fine
she had her period She was changing her
temper and she missed the lineup a 150
fine I told her I will tell everything
that is happening behind your wall
everything okay the way you run your
establishment is absolutely unacceptable
reciprocating here okay we are under
watch everywhere we're getting check in
our rooms we are not even being trusted
we are on a lockdown because the town
don't want to see us what we have like
some type of disease do we stink or
something what the [ __ ] is going on and
I told her my weight is going back with
me and my 1500 as well well guess what
when my check was sent to me
she didn't take the 1500 I left Cherry's
Ranch at 2 am going back to San Diego
through Death Valley with my car
traveling and like I'm like talking to
my car come on baby come on baby you
can't do this you can do this we can
make it we can make it the car
throttling and I'm thinking if I break
down here I'm so [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm so
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was no car passing me
I had so many hours to Sunday go
come on I arrive in San Diego yeah so I
left Cherry's Ranch and I went right
back to The Love Ranch absolutely you
make less money business [ __ ] what
do you mean I cannot even talk to the
staff so
here you have the Bunny Ranch run by a
man and it's chaotic now you have
cherries Ranch run by only woman that's
why you cannot talk to the staff not to
create conflict of interest it's chaotic
anyway it was horrible there horrible
love ranch was the friendliest one one
morning
friendship when she wake up we have the
HBO production here they want to do
casting with different houses the
different houses with the Benny Ranch
and the larynge
cool this is the show that brought me
here
let's go why not so now I'm having party
car plan and like all the the HBO
producers you know asking me questions
um and I was I remember I was like
really enthusiastic with it I'm like
yeah why not why the [ __ ] not you know I
talk with them and they signed me like
that day they wanted to do a spin-off on
Cinemax about the the fantasy of fantasy
girl so they wanted to actually take us
to Fantasy girl and for once what is
about us our fantasy
and so they picked a few girls to do the
to do the the show on Cinemax and then
next thing you know boom I'm doing the
episode they have a whole segment with
me and uh so my fantasy was to [ __ ] on
rooftop super super high so that angel
can actually watch the show and they
told me can you come to La we're going
to make a a better fantasy reality so we
had like a 3D Banner to make it look
like New York and we're on a rooftop and
here I am with this guy I don't even
remember his name but the one I remember
he was Romanian and we try to
communicate here with my French accent
and him with his Romanian accent and we
could not understand each other so
nobody could understand him and said the
producer and everything so if you watch
the episode you don't hear his voice at
all like I was the only one like who was
allowed to talk because you could not
understand him it was amazing is that it
actually [ __ ] me real good like he
[ __ ] me so good that when they
actually like cut we kept going
the production start leaving one by one
you gotta understand
when you're on a set you have 20 people
okay you don't have one or two people
you have 20 people behind the camera the
Cable Guy the light guy the sound guy
every single guy plus the team that
you're working with like all the girls
that you're working with or are watching
you're literally performing for real
real
and so I told myself okay at one point
like we weren't because my pizza was
supposed to be soft Corey you don't see
in and out you don't see uh no close-up
I mean it's super soft car it's really
really such a bubbly show they did with
it so
I look at one point and I think he looks
phony because we were not actually
[ __ ] foreign
excuse me plus he was hot so I'm like
[ __ ] me for real
so again he [ __ ] me so well okay we
kept going so that was great plus he's
awesome
um you have a hot robe when you're done
with your scene when you're a talent
when they call you the talent
did take care of you I can only imagine
when you like engineer Jolie I mean I
was nothing and they literally like
pampered the [ __ ] out of you on a set
it's awesome so once the HBO show came
out the Cinemax show came out
it was ridiculous it was a bomb in my
life everybody was hooky like uh booking
me uh trying to yeah trying to
get a hold of me you know who is this
guy we need to book her so that was an
amazing amazing time of my life the
whole HBO Cinemax
wrench you Richard the ranches for how
long it was almost three years what was
a crazy story
from all those years so it's not a crazy
story
but um
I think like the one that is like cherry
on top of the top and I'm sorry for my
friends that heard that story so many
times but it really is like a complete
[ __ ] show
one day this this guy this little young
guy lots of tattoos quite young little
thuggish is there lineup
I
crossed any speaking me let's go let's
go let's go easy enough I'm like baby
boy like calm down a little bit your
heart
a bowl
of money
who comes out of his pocket almost like
if you would shove bills real fast in
your pocket
mind you I'm an ex-banker so I'm looking
at him like
like a nightmare I'm putting the beers
his bunch of ones or fives of tens of
twenties and I'm thinking are you
working on tips like what's wrong with
you
you know treat your money better than
that let's go let's go like yeah 600
bucks so I tell him baby boy honestly we
start we're not going to do much you
know how much time we have 15 minutes
like perfect
that was the easiest negotiation of my
[ __ ] life let's go let's go let's go
we go to the window boom we [ __ ]
I mean this little boy [ __ ] me so hard
the bed moved
click click click all the way to the
middle of the room okay we [ __ ] like
rabbits he [ __ ] like it was a genuinely
his last day on Earth and it was buckler
for that story so now we don't it it was
quite quick honestly best [ __ ] of my
life but quite quick and we have those
few minutes where it's like recuperating
it's gonna have a heart attack this poor
thing and I'm on his chest like this and
I must have asked him the question what
do you do in life like tell me a little
bit about you
he's like you're never gonna believe me
I like try me and he's like I'm a bank
robber I'm on the run
yeah [ __ ] come on you know I was a
banker and you're a bank robber like I'm
like come on tell me a story and he
tells me yeah I [ __ ] go with my gun
and tell them like give me the cash I'm
like there is no way we have the note
robbery and then we have the Takeover
robbery nobody really does the Takeover
robbery because you know you're gonna
get hurt with the note in and out bam
when you do a takeover it's another
story
and not believing even closely is
[ __ ] story and he's I'm like why you
do that and he's telling me for them so
then he shows me picture of two little
girls
okay I'm sure mommy is super proud of
daddy being a cowboy around America
robbing banks
and he's telling me she's deceased
I'm like come on Mark seriously what do
you think I I think in my head I'm like
this guy is a bullshitter so I tell him
you know you already paid me you don't
have to like tell me what this [ __ ]
to like you I really like you you [ __ ]
me so good so we don't I will never
forget mark
he holds my face he keeps me on my
forehead you're not gonna tell on me
right I tell him I'm going to take a
microphone and tell everybody I had like
a few GT [ __ ] me so good run for
restaurant
now it's very important detail
I am leaving the Parlor I'm going to
take my shower and after every session I
smoke a joint
well mind you I'm taking a shower I'm
rolling half a joint when she come to
the office so I'm pulling that joint
open
in the dwar of my nightstand very
important detail I'm going to the office
I see four police officers
okay you need to sit down but I I am
[ __ ] okay I think that they're gonna
rain my room with the weed in my [ __ ]
nightstand okay so I'm thinking what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on so I'm
sitting down like
ready to get whipped and they're like
and The Madam is like Frenchy we need to
know
um more more of the guy that just booked
you the guy that you just parted with
I'm like
why it's like it just rubbed Dayton
grocery store
okay I'm like
the ball of money
Dayton grocery store now posts 30
minutes before the [ __ ] [ __ ]
robbed Dayton grocery store went to the
ranch got an eyewitness that followed
him all the way to the ranch no cell
phone back then it's 10 years ago the
[ __ ] the little redneck guy that
followed him all the way to the ranch
goes all the way to Carson City to call
the cops by the time the cops which mean
the cops arrive that's the window I took
a shower and I rode half a joint that's
the window between when the little guy
left and the cops arrived that's the
window of where they could burst inside
of the room and see the whole like bed
moving from the from the middle of the
room and so I'm asking them like but how
you know it seems so they're explaining
him yeah there is a guy and I witness
that followed him I'm like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got to be [ __ ] me so they're
asking me can you tell us more about him
like a description you had a lot of
tattoo I'm like but to tell you I was a
Jewish officer uh the last thing I was
really looking at was his tattoos you
know
I was not looking nice that serious at
all
so I don't give much of a description
what I what I remember is when I left
the office is the is the office and the
Parlor and all the girls obviously
everybody knows everything so like
Frenchie okay you're okay are you in
trouble there is [ __ ] four police
officer wants to talk to me I'm like
girls
the cow just picked me at the lineup is
a fugitive the [ __ ] just like
literally robbed data in grocery store
and spent the money of the robbery on me
are you joking me so as of today I think
this is the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] that
happened to me 100 you know but yeah and
I would never know what happened to this
kid but that window of like maybe like
six seven minutes
was what he had to get out yeah so maybe
I'm even very best last [ __ ] before I
got incarcerated yeah the true story and
I do not believe the [ __ ]
and please you guys because I know a lot
of you are not believing my story
everything is 100 True everything that
comes out of my mouth is 100 True
including your accent
even my accents
um
no I mean every every single video on my
channel somebody says they're lying no
so this is you know the brothels are
probably like some somewhere in the
middle between girls that work the
street and girls that are doing what
you're doing today which is a high end
different
like like the the girl that work in the
street with pimps you know somebody is
making money out of them a brothel it's
a full business they're making money out
of us they're charging 50 you know and
the Nicole and diamonds for this this so
we're not really technically making 50
no this is why we have to charge so much
other ranches yeah and there is a lot of
money to make absolutely like it was
like like [ __ ] the money they give
you there you know all it takes is like
that one drunk millionaire that arrives
he just made like a lot of money at the
casino it's free money for him boom like
it was very very like fast to make money
the girls also would be slick with them
they would roofie the guy completely I
witnessed it countless time I wasn't a
party
we should get like I remember his heart
beating so hard they made him shot a
shot on the house but it was ecstasy
inside yeah and the guy is really like
tripping okay his heart is beating and
I'm looking at the ground like we're
going to [ __ ] hell are you kidding me
you know are you serious because she
told me in my hair like
I'm like you did not you know I'm
getting put in a party where the guy is
completely drugged out and I'm like just
like trying to reenture him his dick
he's definitely not working his heart is
being like this I love you girls I love
you girls the time is up is in a bad
trip you can see when the time was up
and he's like I just spent four thousand
dollars for those two girls not even
getting it up he's going into a bad trip
can I stay longer can I say longer so
then she's hustling him because she was
good at that like when we need more baby
we need more I'm seeing like I'm out I'm
out like no no no no for me Journey
money is not money you're going to keep
anyway it's common money it's karma
money it's not gonna stay with you
that's why they broke all the time those
girls
the more you hustle the more you broke
Karma it really is dirty money it's
money that you did not do with your
passion with your heart with the actual
genuine trade they pay you for a good
time give them a good time then you keep
the money but if you're getting paid to
give them about time it's karma money I
like I remember a girl same thing I um
she puts me in a party she Whispering my
hair jump on his face jump on his face
so here he is like licking my [ __ ]
doing her face pocket she's literally
going through his pocket I'm literally
look I'm like
I'm like oh I I can't I can't I can't
like I can't do this [ __ ] so after a
while when you're around this very toxic
environment that is not really you you
know what I mean
um as soon as I could [ __ ] get out I
got out yeah yeah yeah like they give
you a legal platform by all means but
please give us a legal platform where
you check on the girl if you check if
the bus is not testing the girl's [ __ ]
against the bed or make sure that it's
not a toxic environment because it
genuinely is
[ __ ] you know the drug is around and I
remember consciously the day consciously
the day I decided to never do drugs it
was in the room of one of the girl at
the ranch and she was doing a line of
cocaine and her nose bleeds and she's
facing back and forth with a cotton
bowl and one is like clogged and the
other one is bleeding and she's back and
forcing like you can see she's in her if
she want to do a line but she killed her
body won't would not allow her and I
remember the vision of that was like
well that could be and I consciously
decided that day you will never sniff
anything ever and so far so good I will
not sniff anything I don't find it
necessary for me
you know you enjoy your work you enjoy
your clients right
there's a very few of the girls that do
sex work
can say that most of them hate their
clients
but it's very unfortunate just just like
the mechanic like let's say that you
work on car and you hate cars let's say
that you work during interview and you
hate your interviewers or let's let you
you make you know anything in life and
you hate it yeah it's important to love
what you do
but yes so not to traumatize yourself
and actually lose your soul in the
process of it where is the point this is
a journey on Earth that you have skies
the limit of your choices of what you
can do with your decisions and you're
going to really decide to be always
where it hurts or it's uncomfortable no
why would you do that how insane is that
that's really crazy for me I think I bet
you because you love what you do and you
believe that what you provide is is
worth a higher price you can
comfortably charge that price and then
keep the money because you feel you
deserve it whereas all these girls that
are working the street and hustling
people go broke every day
yeah baby girl because they don't
believe they deserve it if you go well
if you're going to give the money to a
manager that's going to make you believe
you know he's going to do great thing
with that money yet but you believe you
deserve to be taken
yeah
yeah we get what we believe we deserve I
think we are then and then we we get
what is imposed on us and you don't have
the boards to say no yeah there is that
too you know but yeah no those girls
they should really really wake up and to
realize they really don't need the juice
and if you do at least have a pimp that
does things right I met only one
technically they did things right in
Miami I gotta say this [ __ ] get
this game right and I'm gonna tell you
why mark when I arrived it was actually
a friend who needed some cook okay in
Miami was before a party and wanted to
get some coke so I went with him to this
mansion
Dimensions was a pimp
he had at least 20 girls working for him
in a mansion swimming pool you know
actually was not Miami was Fort
Lauderdale
nice [ __ ] house beaches everywhere
sexy and he said one thing
I am a red bottom pimp
all these girls did not have no Aldo
shoes that you have no slippers on no
they had nice [ __ ] shoes because the
guy understood that if I put nice and
elegant things on those girls are gonna
bring money and they're going to show
all the girls look that Daddy is
actually spoiling the [ __ ] out of me so
all the girls wanted to work for him and
the more girls wanted to work for him
the more work for him all he had to do
is just collect the money from the 20
girls 20 yeah at least
go buy a pair of shoes every once in a
while and keep them happy like this that
makes sense now you have those stupid
wannabe baby boy pimp that is going to
tattoo your face
right there you don't have a businessman
taking care of your money since if he
tattoos you tattoo your his name on your
face nobody is gonna really book you
that he's a businessman with this
possible income you're gonna have like
General ass [ __ ] who's gonna
book you if you look like a ghetto [ __ ]
wake up wake up you know seriously
so right there you don't even have a
good businessman since he does not even
understand that by doing this is right
there preventing you from making the
money for the rest of your life as you
said one of our phone calls recently why
work the street when you can work the
suite
I told you that yeah like you have
you have a date in the car
the way I do my dates is in a Jacuzzi
with nice champagne a beautiful sweet
you know my lights like everything going
on is gorgeous
I would not be able to do what they do
not at all and at the end of the story
they can do exactly the same thing that
they do in a car
but in a better more
like glamorous setting at the end of
story we're doing the same thing girl
we're doing the same exact thing
but I decided to instead to get 10 Dates
at 60 bucks I'm going to charge right
away 600 for one
instead to go through 10 plus when you
have one situate you limited yourself
versus when you have the internet like
now like everybody can see you exist you
only exist in one street versus now your
exposure is like by what like a thousand
more
I think if you're a smart peep buy a
computer put your gun on a on the
internet and don't have her on the blade
are you kidding me you really guys call
that the blade I can only imagine those
girls going there like respect girl
respect respect what you do
I die I die
no way no way I did not come on Earth
saw that
too scary not worth it
no but I do need your lighter
no
it's going to be a PBS smart people if
you're gonna do
if you're gonna do anything be smart
about it or don't do it at all
you know I hate pimps Mark I hate them
I hate pimps I just don't like them that
one in Miami but at least I say more as
like a businessman more than anything it
was not gorilla at all I did a lot of
crap from my viewers because
I'll say there are some pimps that are
not exploited bastards and that's what
I'm talking about guys that are like
what you just described in Miami no I
was a gentleman this guy yeah like any
trees borderline Charming born
borderline that's the thing yeah the
girls the girls were in Forest they were
being taken care of I loved it they
loved it they loved him that's that's
the only pimp I'm talking about it was
like genuinely getting worship
um not one time it was it would you know
lay hands on them that's the 70s style
of pimp 1970s I would not even know yeah
or 80s maybe but but now it's like these
gang member pimps are just getting the
girls addicted and
taking advantage of
them baby girl wake up you can do it
you're not on Earth to be anybody's
pooching ball or definitely not on Earth
to give a [ __ ] you don't even
need your money and if you do make sure
you put red bottom shoes on you okay
because guess what in one night you can
in one night you can go to Neiman Marcus
but everything you want so if he's not
doing that for you he's not a good
manager hello is a woman who's
attractiveness or sex appeal the
ultimate commodity in our in our culture
if you want to make money no but it's
it's almost more powerful than
power for a man
or it's equal
no nothing is equal but um I mean being
a woman of course is going to come with
you know perks
just like comes with perks to come to be
with to be a man you know yeah so are we
going to take advantage of it I mean
you're not going to take advantage of
your Force for example you can lift but
you're gonna pretend you cannot lift
some with a woman if we can you know
wrap yourself around our finger we're
going to do that if we can you know
yeah that was a question
I'm just asking if it's it's a hell of a
commodity I think it's under under us
under it's awesome to be a woman you
have flying her face
I wear your your feet touch the ground
boom
you are you're flying off he's the girl
that understood that like yeah they're
successful the whole world becomes a
playground I start going internationally
Japan Southeast Asia
everywhere no agent to Dubai that's my
girlfriend no I don't do Dubai no but uh
no I did like a lot of countries
um why limited yourself there when you
can go all over the world yeah but you
understand what you have yourself
absolutely there's a lot of girls just
never they don't see what they have well
wake up baby girl your mom spent nine
months to create something beautiful so
you might as well a good good thing with
it you know and not give it to a
[ __ ]
uh-uh no she would be very disappointed
Do You Believe In Love
again yeah I do believe in love
um for me personally it's complicated
because I know too much
I think that I I've been around men so
much that I just know them that makes
sense I cannot really play me I see them
coming 10 miles away I see the game and
I genuinely don't want to play the game
I want something super organic so I have
awesome short little stories because I
travel a lot so I'm going to meet super
awesome [ __ ] on the way like
genuinely like I tell some of them we
making the Hollywood movie jealous right
now it's not even funny because it's so
intense while we're living but it's
temporary it's a travel the distance
um the distance is for real I met a guy
from Berlin for example from Croatia I'm
gonna get from France from Italy I
usually like the European guys I click
with them I think the way I need to
click with
a man Americano so that's funny because
I'm really great at having great dates
with American clients but I cannot date
them
but French guys for example I cannot
work with in France I tried this really
strange and odd I cannot click and
switch into Francesca like I'm French so
I can like play the little accent and
everything like it doesn't work no more
so
yeah so I don't know I never really work
in France so it feels like I can date
the French guy but not make money with
them I cannot date the American guys but
I can make money with them it's very
strange
very strange and I mean it's been you
know 20 years in this country so I know
like it's not really coming from me or
from them it's just not clicking the way
I click with the European guy
there is no I love them so my I'm very
limited of um finding somebody that can
make one with why do you believe in it
why the [ __ ] not no come on
what do most women not understand about
men
what have you learned
that women could could use for
themselves oh there's a lot they don't
understand about men
but I think a a woman really genuinely
is going to think that she is the only
pitch for him
but the thing is even her if she eats
some Peach every day she's gonna get
sick of that pitch a smart woman is
going to understand let's make like
let's be like the two of us against the
world but realize the world is still
against us and I know temptation is
going to be against this so as a smart
woman and knowing how men works
let's not join behind my back let's do
it together personally I am really open
I'm not particularly jealous because I'm
comfortable and confident maybe I can
actually
pick up a girl for him but I need to be
there it cannot be something behind my
back because the thing is once I give
you that chance
to do it with me and you still do it
behind my back double betrayal double
betrayal but if you're a woman not
giving the option and you still cheat on
you behind your back and you don't suck
your stick on a daily basis
are you that good of a wife you know and
same thing for men I'm not glamorizing
nothing right now man if you don't
reinsure your wife she's never going to
be down for that [ __ ] so reinsure her
make sure she's in her spot of like the
exclusive one
because once a woman is reinsured
especially we insecure as [ __ ] women are
insecure to start with so once you
reinsure her and you open the door of
like let's go to a swinger club or let's
call
an escort tonight and have fun with her
now she's not insecure to say yes or no
like she might consider it because she
is now reinsured with you but if you are
not reinsuring you're already insecure
wife
and you want to open the door of like
let's swing what do you think she's
gonna say
something I mean it's on both like it
takes two to tango yeah what do men not
understand about women
reinsurance
if you need to have your dick sucked
three times a day we need to be
reinsured three times a day boom that's
it that's done easy it's actually that
simple
you know
yeah
it's not really hard
so we're not meant to be monogamous
men
no human humans no
well I want to tell you I think
it's very strange
there is no tomatoes
because we're individuals
and just like animals let's say for
example
he likes to put his seat everywhere he
needs to make new Pride okay but then
you also have the penguin that make one
for life
humans are like that and every Spectrum
in between I believe you're gonna have
the lion who wants to put his dick
everywhere and then you're gonna have
that man that one was enough
then separable that's soul mate right
there
and they all exist
and everything in between
so we can talk about this for a long
time because because Sky becomes the
limit you have to generalize and say all
men are this way are all men are
supposed to generalize we are in two
videos
you know so there is no intimate choice
there is none
we would know he would be on the
Internet by now
so yeah
yeah definitely
interesting between
um men and women we complement each
other so well
and at the same time we are quite
opposites yeah for sure
a lot we don't understand about each
other
and we guess and we assume
yeah that's why communication is key
communication is everything oh really
when like you know women we're like good
at being like
yeah whatever like I'm going out have
fun but really we don't want him to go
out but we have this way of just like
saying it for like we don't mean it like
say it like you do you know for me
communication is very important that's
why maybe
um
uh I do need a [ __ ] who is like
a thick skin with me because I'm not
gonna sugarcoat I want sugar coats if
you do something I'm like I'm seeing
what you're doing I'm gonna literally
put the [ __ ] in front of like
what he's doing and now we're having an
accurate moment and the guys they will
not be able to handle that far too long
with me yeah so I need like organic
organic organic or nothing yeah
it really is nice for me
for sure
your life is getting better my life yeah
this seems like it's getting better that
mean that it was bad at one point I made
you it's great no it's good you seem
pretty happy and it seems like this is
probably a better time for you than
maybe in your 20s
yeah for sure because now I know what I
know you know so in the 20s you have the
the
physical really like you like hotter but
you're quite naive and then you kind of
like crisscross when you now I'm pushing
40 so imagine but now like I'm feeling
like ageless I'm not feeling
young old I'm feeling like kind of like
stuck in between
you know and uh with everything I know
though so my fuses get super short my
choices get wiser for sure
um
but definitely now I learned how to say
no
what was yes and one point is no now
yeah and I learned how to approach
situation
like even dangerous
situation like a [ __ ] professional
that's why life would give you and the
years would give you yeah so I'm way
happier now in those years than when I
was when I was 20 so it's not enough
tool and data
to face life and the problem and
situation that he was throwing at me
that makes sense
you said in the in the first talk we did
that you're
you're a sexual artist
absolutely and I think doctor would
people that negotiate with artists don't
understand
this is maybe why actors are paid so
much and certain artists are paid so or
they're compensated so so greatly is
when you're dealing with an artist you
have to make sure they're smiling
they're happy they're they're they're
really into what they're doing and the
way to do that sometimes is overpay them
or pay them
in a grand in a grand way because
otherwise then they have a bad attitude
and you're not going to get crap out of
them sure absolutely yeah and that's
what a lot of people that negotiate with
artists and you're an artist I mean you
need to make them
oh my God I can't believe how much
they're paying me I'm gonna give them
the best thing I can possibly do no for
sure I give them definitely a show I
actually like say many times it's almost
like actually like I'm going into this
city and this city I'm gonna tour here
and here and they literally pre-booking
the show you know and um personally I am
not the one that decides my race it's my
phone
my phone is my pimp
I'm gonna tell you how if my phone does
not ring
it means that I'm charging too much like
whatever I'm actually asking does not
make no sense and nobody is actually
booking me if I'm charging too low my
phone will blow the [ __ ] up okay if I'm
at the same price as
um
a ghetto girl you know if they're going
to all call me everybody so I'm going to
wonder why my phone is blowing up so
much right so my rate of matter is my
phone
when it rings just to my liking all
right that's my rate that's it and I'm
not being delusional or anything as long
as your phone rings
you're still in the base again I told
you like this is not really you decide
to retire from the Beast it's impossible
it's the bees who decides to retire from
you want your phone does not ring no
more you don't once the car doesn't stop
for you no more you don't it's the job
retiring from you you know the best is
to actually retire from the job before
you retirees from you but you have to be
smart doing that getting out of this
game is probably difficult
it's complicated mark
absolutely very complicated as a matter
of fact at the Bunny Ranch he was a 19
year old little girl doing journalism
studies she was a student and she was
going to the ranch to
you know pay for her study and
um I was fascinated by her I have to say
this little 19 year old she was barely
legal she could not even go to the bar
to do the bar her soul you know and she
was making a lot of money this little
girl like a lot of money and guess what
when I came back to the ranch was there
still
yeah so she never left people get
addicted she never left actually she has
a SLK blah blah blah Mercedes and she
comes with you know all her nice little
stuff she never quit the job because why
would you when you search in high
demands
I'm going to tell you the difference
between a prostitute
and an escort or a sex artist
a prostitute she's asking you have money
for me you have money for me who has
money for me who has money for me
somebody has money for me an escort is
the client's like I have money for you
hey Frenchie I have money for you do you
want my money and I'm like
all right no you you weird
um yeah
next week
see what I mean big difference huge so
you prostitute I'm not a prostitutional
I'm a six artist I sprinkle magic in
your life I don't do card dates I
actually have like three four hundred
dollar hotel suites when I host
um jacuzzi usually you know so we can
you know like
be mermaids together you know I whisper
to the dolphin right so
yeah we can do that
there's trade-offs with everything we do
in life
what trade what what are you what
compromises are you making or what what
are you giving up by by living this
endless party having a normal
relationship yeah you're not getting the
intimacy I'm having everything I want
every single life everything but
true love and want to make one with not
yet no no and you see that one thing I'm
just witnessing like ah she's like yeah
like they're so cute and so here I eat
my popcorn and I don't hate on them like
what part to you you know I give them
hug I'm like are you exactly what I eat
like yeah they give me what I would
really love to have so the compromise is
that it's impossible to have a normal
relationship Mark either they suck on
you this like it's complicated let's say
that you make more money than him you go
to a expensive restaurant who pays
foreign
ER lover
like okay let me pick up the bill and he
lets me it's like oh let's pretend
you're not a millionaire and it's still
weird because I'm still the lady and I
still want the guy to pick up the bill
at the restaurant even though like I
know again you know what I mean so it's
a complicated in both ways I don't want
to be with a rich dude I don't want a
guy to suck on me I want to be equal
with somebody and make like a beautiful
umpire together but
it's not happening right now it's just
it's difficult to find that connection
I took what life brings me and so far I
have those short little stories that I
embrace absolutely awesome and they give
me orgasms so I'm not going to spit on
them right
even though the last one was like
a minute ago yeah organic sex type of
yeah
if you remove my job yeah I will not
never have sex
and be like a real non [ __ ] yeah are you
are you lonely
absolutely not no I'm not Lonely no no
no I'm very surrounded almost too much
to wear like
people can either join me or
you know like uh charge me like charge
me up join me so like
I have those moments where I need to be
around and moments where I need to
genuinely like a Long Wolf isolate
myself from the back so I can recharge
on my own you know so I'm ambivert I go
back and forth yeah using the feed off
the craziness and all the not crazy
crazy but I
oh I like to party yeah you're a party
girl for sure very very much so when I
uh dance or [ __ ] I don't think
I graded shreds like so when you [ __ ]
you go in a dress and so when you dance
like hours and hours on end like I can
find myself doing I go in such a trends
that if you start talking to me like I'm
actually mad I'm talking to the music
okay
I was just going and I cannot think no
more about problem stress nothing I just
I just have a question with the music
yeah so I [ __ ] a lot and I party a lot
is it wrong I mean [ __ ]
that's my my method of surviving this
this crazy freaking planet everybody
needs to escape even the animals
they get drunk off the fruit coming down
the trees did you see that
they went until the fruit to fermentate
and they get drunk off of it so if the
animals are gonna do that it's only fair
in our highest society that we cannot
find Escape here and there you know
personally I don't go too deep into the
Escape but I try to keep the Escape as
organic as I can
um don't put your escape to like um
chemically like this chemical this
chemical it's an illusion that
once you genuinely can put yourself like
in ecstasy without the Ecstasy now you
win you know it is possible I leave it
all the time that's why I got there to
the party without ecstasy feeling like I
am on
you know I'm the only ones walking
joints at festivals you want cookie on
this I'm like
my joint thanks
so many men seem to think they're the
world's greatest lovers
oh yeah
yeah they're cute what inside would you
can you give on that uh
like the world's best lover you're gonna
have a lot of phone calls from olya
bulikos if you have no phone code from
the girl you [ __ ]
you're not good if you're getting a lot
of calls you might be good
that's what I see
you know but yeah guys guys uh do need
reinsurance actually as well just as
much as women yeah they do need it yeah
for sure yeah that's that's when the
therapy side of my job comes up comes
along
your mind is a little bit twisted but
your your dick is fine you know like one
told me I'm broken like you're not
broken your mind is broken I asked them
usually when like they have Ed erectile
dysfunction I'm like you're totally fine
baby boy you're totally fine at night do
you get hard yes do you ejaculate yes
I'm like guess what you have no problem
it only happens around women then it's
your head see I just give like a million
dollar free consultation to whole
YouTube here is that easy I I've told
you this on the phone that you should
charge the money as a therapist
eventually yeah because you're more of a
therapist than a than a sex worker yeah
and like couple therapy yeah all that
sex therapy for sure yeah like I love to
fix them I love situations like I like
like when they have like a little
problem boom I fix it the body language
changes it feels like I kind of like
I don't know mission accomplished with
this one
yeah and and you have so much experience
with this and so much yeah such a wide
range of different
types of clients you've had I I bet you
have a wealth of knowledge that you
could Market yeah I told you at this
point I can like teach even yeah I can
like not only teach other girls but you
know um definitely teach you know my uh
my clients that
yeah I mean you're you're not going to
age out of this you'll just transition
into something I don't know Mike I have
no idea again like I let like life
unfolds naturally
inorganically
um
I have a lot of things internationally
that happens also to me so it's very
possible I consider not staying in
America you know and um actually you
know base myself somewhere else just to
start a new chapter a new adventure
maybe something else so I can force
myself not to be around it it's too
tempting you know do I want to do that
all my life no because there is an
evolution you know so I to therapy side
of it here eventually being a couple
therapist a sex therapist I would love
that yes but helping children making
shelters for any more stuff like that
like I've been like this since I'm
little like I'm like the girl that would
pick up the broken puppies you know so
there is all these things in my in my
head like all right like okay being
successful successful check how can I
give back now on a really big scale
everybody is offering me projects we can
make this money and this money and you
know Mark like I really am not
interested by it like I
I refuse a lot of projects I tried not
to add on to my plate too much because I
don't think money is to complete you
know happiness it contributes to it but
it's not everything we talked about it
earlier we can quickly be stressful when
you are so dedicated making that money
it comes with the stress as well
I'm not stress so if less money means
less stress let's make less money I
don't give a [ __ ] of money I don't I
really don't if you're doing something
like this for the money you're doing it
for the wrong reason oh I'm not doing
this on the money but like with me with
this channel it's like you know if if I
was doing this for the money I wouldn't
have the wherewithal to keep doing it
yeah you do with passion yes I love what
I'm doing so I do it and usually that
leads to money
if you do yes things actually
effortlessly comes to you it's actually
like almost like oh wow we're running
wow that was a fortnight yeah I think
the audience
can can sense that you're doing it for
the right reasons
yeah I mean seriously yeah I'm not lost
he's definitely not from the drugs he's
not for the money anymore because once
you start having something you kind of
like not doing it for that you know I
had my period of time where you buy like
all this material like oh my God like
and then you realize it's just stuff
you know it's really just tough how much
of what your love for this is is about
learning
Everything 100 of it yeah same with me
for sure like what I'm doing is it's all
about I just love learning
about people about myself about
psychology about everything
yeah and this jump touched me everything
and I'm sure you
you learned a lot from you know dealing
with other situations those humans like
there is like human situations you have
a new existed and boom now you have
somebody talking about that so yeah it's
super interesting to be a human yeah I
think so
really yeah learning is the ultimate
reason for doing all these things
and growing yeah thank you for people's
mistake as well so I don't have to make
it like
you know yeah like they give me of the
vision that I absolutely don't want to
be
no no no
so yeah I learned I learned a lot
for sure School of Life though I was not
scholar but I think I'm good at life
I learned I learned fast one mistake I
don't do it again then it's Insanity you
know
um
yep Frenchy thank you so much for
sharing your wisdom again and your
stories
time to go to bed huh you're amazing
yeah way past my bedtime your your
evening your evening is just starting
them Mark and I are having a good day no
we're not yeah we are
hey
you're fine
it was awesome